it's the second Sunday since the
earthquake
the antakia Protestant church is
resuming services
but the pastor now balances atop what
used to be the wrought iron gate
with Bible in hand
we walk five minutes along deserted
streets to find the Greek Orthodox
Church
we stop a rare passerby to ask where
it's gone
and the Habibi El Najjar mosque believed
to be built in the 7th century was one
of the oldest in the country
now in Ruins
antakia known as Antioch in ancient
times was one of the biggest jewels of
the Roman Empire in modern turkey it's a
city celebrated for its diversity
there is Brotherhood here not
discrimination we all live together here
our churches here our mosque is here
they're all next to each other we are
one nation one fist
it's not just religious history that's
been lost a Thai's house of parliament
built before the area became part of
turkey is now tilting precariously
it's impossible to describe seeing such
a beautiful city like this in Ruins I
hope we'll return to our good old days
this is a beautiful city and I love it
so much and I'm not going to leave
the minister of culture and tourism says
antakya and hitai Province are a mosaic
a place where historically and until
today adherents of the three
monotheistic religions found a home to
worship the government is promising to
rebuild damaged Heritage sites like this
one within a year introduce regulations
for reconstruction and provide financial
assistance to private building owners
will return to its diverse community and
tolerant days we will return and
continue to preserve the culture of
antakia
[Music]
to mention that Antarctica
by multiple earthquake since the second
century each time it was rebuilt they
say history will repeat itself
Natasha ganim Al Jazeera antakia turkia